>>Female Presenter: Hi I'm Heather with the
Cinema Club here at Google LA.
And we're real excited to welcome Jerry Zucker.
Of course, we're gonna have the other two
directors come but they couldn't make it at
the last minute.
>>Jerry: Ahhh
>>audience member: Yay Jerry!
[applause and cheers]
>> presenter: We're really grateful and honored
to have him.
>>Jerry: They don't really like you.
[laughter]
>> presenter: And some of the movies that
all three of them did.
Obviously "Airplane."
But "Top Secret."
They did the "Naked Gun" series.
And "Ruthless People."
Jerry's films that he's directed include "Ghost",
"First Night" and "Rat Race" and maybe you
have others that you wanna talk about as well.
And so please join me in welcoming Jerry Zucker.
[applause and cheers]
>>Jerry: Ah.
Thank you it's a pleasure to, pleasure to
be here.
This is an amazing, I this is an amazing workspace.
I don't know how any of you get anything done.
[laughter]
I mean, it's like, it's every ten feed it's
either an exercise place or an eating place
or a you know, gathering place.
But anyway.
So.
What?
>>male audience member: We gotta put it on
and work it off.
>>Jerry: Exactly.
No, no, but it's pretty amazing.
You all probably know how lucky you are, to
have a place like that.
I mean, I don't know how.
They might beat the crap out of you while
you're working.
[laughing] You know.
But the building is great.
Actually, we were all supposed to be here
today.
I apologize for Jim.
He had to go to a conference.
He's, Jim is very involved with pediatric
epilepsy and he went to a, he left, he had
an emergency meeting in Chicago I think.
Or somewhere.
About this conference that they're holding.
Anyway, and I talked to my brother David today
and he was "Ah, Jerry" [imitating brother].
So that didn't work out.
I guess I'll really mostly wanna answer your
questions.
I'll just, I guess, talk a little bit about
this film.
It started when we were doing this thing called
Kentucky Fried Theater.
And Kentucky Fried Theater was live skits
and also we had a video monitor.
This was really in the early days of video
with reel-to-reel video in this big machine.
It's like this big.
And it is amazing 'cause the machine was like
this big, and half inch reel-to-reel and really
heavy.
And a big cord tethered to a camera.
And it was black and white and not nearly
as good as my iPhone.
You know.
In terms of picture quality.
[laughter] So it's hard to imagine how they,
how you do that.
But the, so we used to set the video tape
machine to go on in the middle of the night
where some of the corniest commercials were.
'Cause we would do spoofs on them.
And one night we caught this movie called
"Zero Hour" which is this 1957 flying movie
with Dana Andrews, Sterling Hayden, Elroy
Hirsch, being some fairly well known names
at the time.
They probably don't mean a lot to you now
but--.
And we were looking at the commercials but
then we kinda got engrossed in the movie.
And the interesting thing about this movie
and the whole genre, it kind of was that we
made fun of it.
But we also loved it.
You know?
And that sort of, everything we did in terms
of satire, we had to have both.
We had to find it laughable and we also had
to have some affection for it.
And I think you can kind of see that in "Airplane."
And a lot, you know, for us it was this really
tough, hard-hitting style of drama that we
grew up with.
Both on TV and in the movies.
The B movies in particular.
And the Charlton Heston school, whatever.
Anyway.
And so we said "Gee, maybe we should make,
this would make a funny movie."
And so we didn't really know a lot about writing
movies.
But we took, the three of us, while we were
doing the show, or, were working on it.
And then we put it down for a while 'cause
we couldn't.
We finished it but we couldn't get it going.
Interestingly enough, someone offered to buy
it.
But we didn't wanna sell it 'cause we didn't
trust anybody to do it right.
And even when we were nothing, we had, we
didn't have anything.
And I think someone was offering us a couple
hundred thousand dollars or something if it
got made, and that may have been a lot of
money.
But we grew to love it and we didn't want
anybody to mess it up.
Particularly the casting which was probably
the most important thing to us.
Well, two things.
They're part of the same thing.
The casting and the tone.
To play it totally straight.
When we were on the set we used to, and when
we spoke with the actors before we hired them,
we told them "We don't want you to play it
straight.
We want you to pretend that you don't know
you're in a comedy."
And there's a difference.
'Cause when you say "play it straight", a
lot of people kinda think they're playing
it straight.
But really they're, it's for the actor it's
about still about them being funny.
And them making people laugh.
And we really, that's what we really wanted
to reign in.
You act like you have no idea that this is
funny.
[laughter]
That you think you're doing a serious movie.
And that's kinda why we just didn't trust
anybody.
And insisted on directing it when we finally
did get to Paramount.
And they said "OK."
They said they liked the script.
They tried to, they brought up names of current
movie directors that were established successful
directors and wanted someone else to direct
it.
And we kind of said, no, we need to do that.
It was really for that reason, not that we
thought we were gonna be great directors.
But we just, this was our baby and even the--.
Every studio in town turned it down until
we got to Paramount.
And Michael Eisner was having dinner with
a woman named Susan Baerwald, who was a reader
at United Artists.
And he said "What have you read recently that
you like?"
And she said "Well, there's this one script,
'Airplane'."
And she described the film to him and said
"I sent it through with high recommendations
and they passed on it."
And Eisner got up from the table, called Jeff
Katzenberg and said "Track this thing down."
'Cause he just thought that sounded, a comedy
on an airplane, was a great idea.
And the idea that it was low budget.
[laughter]
And so they were great.
And they were helpful.
And there's another interesting thing.
Eisner insisted, we had written it to be done
on a prop plane.
Because that's what "Zero Hour" was.
And in fact I think we wanted to do it black
and white, even.
Because we were so, we were too into that
whole thing.
And Eisner, to his credit, said "No."
Well what he said was, he said "You can do
it in black and white and with a prop plane
but not at this studio."
[laughter]
But I always, I've talked to him recently
and I always thank him.
He was absolutely right about that.
And, but what they never really quite, the
casting.
They said "OK, OK, you can have Nielsen and
Bridges and Stack."
'Cause we were very insistent about that.
But they wanted to put a lot of comedy cameos
in it.
People from, actors that were on TV shows
at the time, on the lot Robin Williams, and
Penny Marshall, and all the Paramount TV show
people, and others.
And, which we didn't really wanna do.
But we went through this process and fortunately
we had this great, one of the producers Howard
W. Koch.
He's not with us anymore.
Wonderful, great guy.
Who at first we thought "Gee, the studio put
him on" and we thought "Ah, do we really want
this old guy on this movie."
And, of course, at the time he was the age
I am now.
[laughter]
But he was terrific.
And he would call--.
He got what we wanted to do.
And so he would call agents and say "You know
what, I'm offering your client this script.
But it's not really gonna be any good."
[laughter]
And they would pass.
And the only one that we ended up with out
of those is Jimmy Walker.
Who is, you know, with the big thing.
Which was fine.
But it wasn't until the first day of dailies
that we got a call from the studio and they
said, and that was the first day of shooting
was Leslie Neilsen in the cockpit saying "I
am serious.
And don't call me Shirley."
Among other things.
And they said "Oh, now we get it."
[laughter]
They really, and I have to say, I don't call
anybody.
Most people really didn't get that and I don't
think, I don't you know ridicule people for
that because it was a difficult concept to
catch, to understand.
Until you really saw how it played.
And for us, this was something we had done
in our videos.
Even with younger actors, just playing it.
Not famous of course.
Just playing it straight.
So it, we were, we had a great experience.
It was helpful for us that we were this little
three million dollar movie.
And at the same time, they were dealing with
the first Star Trek movie.
Which was going way over budget.
So they didn't pay any attention to us.
[laughter]
Which is great and we got the movie made.
The first screening was a disaster.
I mean, they brought in, we, it was longer.
This movie now is 97 minutes.
And I think, and the first one was probably
an hour and 50 minutes.
We just sort of, you know, your first screenings
generally are long and then you.
With satires we go into every movie hoping
that we have 90 minutes that are funny.
But you're always surprised.
And that first screening is always the scariest.
You know?
But in this case, and we hadn't had, it was
the first film we directed, so we hadn't had
a lot of experience with that.
But the guy whose job it was to recruit, they
insisted on doing it on the lot.
The guy didn't do a great job of recruiting.
It, to his defense, it's not that easy to
recruit an audience of people for a comedy
starring Robert Stack.
[laughter] And Leslie Neilsen and Jeffrey
Green.
Lloyd Bridges and Peter Graves.
So they ended up dragging people off the line
from "Mork and Mindy" and "Happy Days" and
all of whatever they were shooting.
And they just, they were, they just weren't
laughing.
Except for one guy.
It was one guy in the audience that "Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha"
He just loved it.
He just kept laughing.
And bless him on beyond, you know a lot of
times people don't like to laugh if everybody
else isn't.
But this guy didn't care.
He's just "Wah-ha-haaaa".
And we edited off of one guy.
[laughter]
You know, you really, you usually try to figure
you want a representative.
You want 300 people.
500 to get a sense.
'Cause everybody doesn't laugh and.
One guy.
[laughter]
So then, the, afterwards, people were coming,
studio people.
And "Well, now, I guess you got a lot of work
here."
And we could see the "Failure!" in their eyes.
[laughter] Actually I should say there was
a screening before that.
That was a funny, the first time we showed
it to the studio, we showed it to Eisner and
I think Katzenberg, too.
And we showed it at Eisner's house, in his
screening room.
Of course you're not looking for big laughs.
'Cause it's just a couple of guys who've read
the script, seen the dailies, etcetera, etcetera.
But his kids who were younger at the time,
were, I don't know, 8 and 10 or 12, whatever.
They were in the projection booth and you
could hear them laughing through the projection
booth.
And Eisner, to his credit, he always had faith.
You know?
And even when all these people said what some
of the other studio executives came out and
said.
More.
You know.
Negative things.
And some who never liked the script and whatever,
were kind of saying, "I was right."
Eisner and Katzenberg always had faith in
it.
And so we've always, you know, had a debt
of gratitude towards them.
No matter how much they tried to fuck us in
the future.
[laughter]
No, no I'm kidding.
It's, you know.
[laughter]
Well, they're our studio executives, you know
what I mean?
[laughter]
Lemme just tell you right now, Paramount didn't
have a masseuse on duty.
It's not like Google where "We want the employees
to be happy."
[laughter]
"A happy worker is a productive worker."
That wasn't the, you could be, what Paramount,
the studios are more the 'you could be fired
tomorrow' method of encouragement.
[laughter]
Anyway, so we finally decided we would, we
need to edit this.
our next screening would be on a college campus.
And we went, where was the first screening?
I think it was, oh gee, somewhere, a UC campus.
And forgive me, I can't think.
Davis, maybe it was.
And that was like, exhilarating.
Because they just loved it.
We, it was better edited, too.
Because thanks to that one guy.
[laughter] I should have gotten his name.
I should really.
Still I'd like to call him and thank him.
But then we did a bunch of college campus
screenings.
And those were just great.
And then, there's just nothing worse than
spending years of your life on a movie and
feeling like it's bombing.
And it's really, it's, we all have a lot of,
I don't know if it's the same in your business
exactly.
But for filmmakers, we have so much of our
own personal whatever tied up in it.
And own egos and worth and all of that kind
of stuff.
That it really, it's hard.
You have to learn not to "zzzz-zzzz-zzzz"
you know.
Because that's the way the business is for
most people.
But it, you know, those screenings were great.
And then pretty much from there it was fairly
smooth.
And then it came one, it was a hit.
But oddly enough, it's funny, I don't think
when we made it then, we ever thought it would
still be around 30 years later.
[laughter]
And people would still, you know what I mean.
And of course we didn't know about, that was
before video.
In those days, a movie had a second release.
Or a re-release.
And so they would like six months later, if
a movie was successful enough, they'd put
it out in theaters again for people who'd
missed it.
And then it was just the television, a few
networks that would periodically maybe show
a movie.
But there was some movies kind of died off
unless they were like "Wizard of Oz" or some,
"Gone with the Wind" the big movies.
But thanks to video, and DVD now, these things
live.
And so it's amazing.
That this thing that we did when we were kids
with, you know.
Sort of carried this, it's almost become more
now than it was then.
In a way.
It's hard for me to gauge.
'Cause I'm inside it.
But it feels like, I mean, people liked it
then.
And it was like "Oh, that was cool."
But I just, I didn't feel then quite like
the god I do know.
[laughter]
>>male #1: We're not worthy, we're not worthy
[laughs]
>>Jerry: [laughing] Thank you, thank you.
No, it has taken on a, I think a different
aura.
But anyway, so that's like a quick overview.
But I'll, so I'd love to answer questions.
Any questions you have.
Go ahead.
>>male #1: My roommate and I are great fans
of all your movies of course.
And also of "Police Squad".
>>Jerry: Ah.
>>male #1: And I gotta ask, "Police Squad"
obviously led into "Naked Gun."
But I wonder what happened that we only have
what?
Half a dozen of this absolutely among the
funniest television ever.
>>Jerry: Thank you.
You know it was a funny thing about "Police
Squad."
We had this, we insisted right off the bat
that there not be a laugh track.
And so ABC said "OK", you know.
They wanted to do the show.
And we got into it and when it was done they
begged us to put a laugh track on it.
We had contractually, we had "You can't do
this without our permission."
And so because the thing is, about that kinda
humor, the whole thing is you're pretending
it's not funny.
And so when we finished the first show, they
wanted us to, they put a laugh track on.
Not that they thought they'd sneak something
by, but they asked us, "Please just look at
it.
Because we think it plays much better."
And we said "No, this is not our humor."
But you know, for television they may have
been right.
For our show, we were right.
And so we never regretted the decision.
But I think the real telling thing was that
Tony Thermopolis when he canceled it, said
it didn't work because you had to watch it.
[laughter]
>>audience member: You had to focus.
>>Jerry: You had to focus.
And it's true, we made it like a film.
Like, people sit in a darkened room facing
the screen and paying attention.
And with television, kind of, you're doing
other, but now you're texting on your phone,
you're doing all kinds of things.
In those days it was, still you're getting
up to get something to eat or you've got a
newspaper or you're talking to some people.
Whatever.
You're just not, and I actually heard you
know, at the time people would tell me when
college students would say, they would all
get together in the dorm at the, in the lounge
or whatever.
And 50 or more would watch it together and
it would play great.
Because then it played like a movie in a way.
And it also is the kinda thing that it always
helps to have an audience for something like
that.
So watching at home without a laugh track,
I don't know.
But for us, we had mixed feelings about it
being canceled because on the one hand, you
don't like to fail at anything.
But on the other hand, we didn't, it was tough
to keep the quality up.
And I don't think we really quite did through
the whole thing.
I mean, I thought was, from our perspective
it was a bit sporadic.
Some great great stuff in it, but a little
bit sporadic.
But when you consider you'd spend, we'd spend
a year to write a movie, and a year between
preproduction and shooting and editing.
So it's at least a two year process.
Making the thing.
And here we're doing 24 minutes a week.
And you have a little more than that 'cause
you start a little earlier and stuff.
But it's still really, and you're shooting
and doing preproduction shooting, editing,
all at once.
It's a three ring circus.
Plus the fact that we couldnít direct them
all ourselves.
We hired other people to direct it and that
was always kind of a mess because it's once
again, our sense of humor.
That kind of satire is just very specific.
So it was hard to just find someone else who
could go in and do that.
And we were not good producers for directors,
in that case.
'Cause we would be saying "No, no, no."
We would be stepping in all the time.
And sort of directing.
And anyway.
>>male #2: First of all, "Airplane."
>>Jerry: I'll repeat it: First of all, "Airplane."
[laughter]
>>male#2: Repeat after me, was one of the
greatest, is one of the greatest comic films
ever made.
Repeat that.
[applause]
>>Jerry: Well, thank you.
>>male #2: Without a doubt, absolutely one
of the greatest comedy films ever made.
>>Jerry: What you mean, "One of?"
>>male #2: Well, it is, it is, it is in its
own category
>>Jerry: One of how many?
A thousand?
No, I'm kidding, go ahead.
[laughter]
>>male #2: It is in its own category and was
followed by many unfunny films.
>>Jerry: Yeah.
>>male #2: That have tried to follow in that
footstep that are not even close.
You go there and you look at them and you
say "Why are these even funny and why do people
think they're funny because they're not and
they're not even the same category with Airplane."
>>Jerry: Bless you.
>>male #2: So yes, it's wonderful to have
all these years later to sit down with you,
and say that this is where you belong for
another hundred years.
>>Jerry: You're so smart.
I didn't
[laughter]
>>male #2: Well, it's in such great company.
One of the
>>Jerry: Well, I mean I knew Google was kind
of a bright company.
It had to be.
But this is beyond what I ever imagined.
>>male #2: Wait until later.
You'll be "Google, what are you talking about?"
>>Jerry: Particularly the way you're dressed,
I didn't expect.
Anyway.
[laughter]
>>Male #2: Google people don't worry about
it, but anyway.
Three million dollars you say was the budget.
It absolutely, I'm sure, held you back from
having complete and total control to do anything
in the world that you'd wanna do.
And it looked like that came across as more
ingenuity.
Do you feel that you were more creative under
the limitations that you had at that time?
Versus today where 50 million would be what
you'd put on the screen there and it would
look incredibly polished but probably not
be a tenth as good of a film.
>>Jerry: Well, that's a good point, you're
exactly right.
There is sometimes, you know, I never want
to say this to a studio, but there is some
creativity gained to a lower budget.
Having to do things for less money.
And by the way, it depends upon the kind of
movie you're making.
I mean, if you're making one of these special
effects movies with a huge landscape, then
I don't know if Avatar would have been helped
by a smaller budget.
[laughter]
But, the, for us, first of all, we kinda,
at that point, I mean we've always had, you
always have budget arguments with studios.
And hopefully you arrive at something that
you can work with.
At the time, for us, we didn't even get--.
The number meant nothing to us.
I mean three million dollars seemed like a
lot.
That's a lot of money.
And we were just thrilled to get out there
and make the movie.
And we, Jon Davison, who is one of the producers
who is, and Howard Koch.
We just trust that they kind of, they would
just say "OK, you've gotta do this.
Shoot this scene in a half a day and this
scene and do you think you can do this and
that.
And if not, then how can we switch around?"
And so, you know, we didn't know in those
days, we were too naive to know that you could
actually just go over budget.
[laughter]
And so we were actually stupid fools.
We were actually hustling trying to make our
days.
Pshh.
Anyway.
So.
No, we, of course, still do that.
But there is, you know, there's another element.
And one thing, there is a certain creativity
to, an energy to moving fast.
But also that's also actually one great thing
about shooting digitally.
Because you can shoot endlessly.
You don't need to yell "Cut!"
You can just, and the actors love it because
it keeps up that energy.
So you know, just moving fast I think kinda
sometimes does the same thing.
But there's another aspect to this particular
film in that, I mean, there's, we like the
cheesiness.
You know?
It wouldn't have been, I don't think, certainly
not any better and probably not as good if
it had been too slick.
I mean, we liked the, we were imitating a
certain style.
So we liked the fact that you could almost
see the strings on the plane.
[laughter]
You know, it's just kinda hanging there.
And it so that, and I think you're also right,
there's on some level, there's actually an
appreciation to doing that.
So anyway.
>>male #3: So the other night I was watching
" Enter the Dragon" with my teenage son.
And couldn't keep a straight face.
Because my parents ill-advisedly took me to
see "Kentucky Fried Movie" when it came out.
And I was just hoping
>>Jerry: Your face isn't that straight anyway
right now.
If I can comment.
No, sorry, go ahead.
>>male #3: So I was hoping you could talk
a little about "Kentucky Fried Theater" and
the origin of that film.
>>Jerry: OK, well, "Kentucky Fried Theater",
we were all at the university in Madison,
University of Wisconsin.
My brother, and Jim Abrams and I.
And we started this theater.
Actually we had seen this thing called "Groove
Tube" which was this guy named Ken Shapiro
got a hold of, had some video tape equipment.
And he made some, a bunch of funny videos.
And what he would do is rent a theater.
And do some advertising, and you'd come in
and there'd be you know, these bunch of chairs
in front of a television monitor.
Or a few monitors around.
And he'd actually put a couple refrigerators
in there where you could go up and get a soda
or something.
And the idea though was that it was stuff
that you couldn't, it was TV but that you
couldn't see on TV.
'Cause this was before cable.
And so television was pretty chaste.
But this, these were all spoofs and some of
them were pretty scatological.
And R-rated and whatever.
And you know, we thought, "Well just, we can
do this."
Actually, my, the story prior to this, a family
friend, a friend of my parents, worked, there
was a, had a sickroom service company.
Where they rented out wheelchairs and that
kinda thing.
And he had this video tape machine that he
would use to demonstrate some of the stuff.
And my father thought.
He said "I talked to Bill and he said he would
let you use this" He's talking to my brother
now who was older and already had graduated
and at the time was working for my dad as
a construction expediter.
Anyway, he said "You know, you can use this
and you can make industrial videos."
'Cause he knew David wanted to get into something
with, you know film.
And industrial videos were not exactly what
David had in mind.
[chuckles] But then when David saw this "Groove
Tube" thing, he drove all the way from Chicago.
He saw it in Chicago.
Drove up to Madison.
And started talking a mile a minute.
"Jerry, we gotta do this.
Da da dad a da.
This we can do."
So we got a hold of the video tape equipment
and actually David just ran into Jim Abrams
in Milwaukee.
And Jim at the time was working as a private
investigator for a law firm.
[laughter]
And he, and the three of us found ourselves
in the basement of our house with this video
tape equipment.
And just having a blast.
And it was the greatest thing because, you
know, you could even though it was that machine
I described earlier, in black and white then.
But you could play it back right away.
You didn't have to send it out to be developed.
And there was no cost to it, you know, unless
you bought another reel of tape.
But even that wasn't very much.
And you could erase it.
And it was just like, we had a, we just had
a blast.
And we laughed and it was the most fun thing.
And then at some point we said, well, "We
gotta show this to people."
We did show, we collected a reel of these
funny things we'd done.
We showed the people and they laughed.
We said "OK, we gotta do something, we gotta
put this."
It's like Mickey Rooney and Judy Garland "Hey,
let's do a show!"
So anyway, it's a long story but finally we
got it all together.
We opened at University of Wisconsin.
There were a bunch of live skits and then
a bunch of video tape and a little bit of
film stuff.
And it was just anything goes, this was 1970.
And it was just at the time that it was OK
to laugh again.
Because this is just post-Vietnam.
Protests and everything at that time was very
political.
The Committee.
The Second City.
These groups would do a lot of political material.
And we were just, you know, zany.
We didn't do any political material, really.
And got skewered for that occasionally in
reviews.
You know, but basically the show was a success
We weren't making a lot of money on it, but
enough to buy more equipment.
But we all had other, I was in school.
And Jim and David had jobs and stuff, and
so for, we, at some point it became not just
a lark.
But like, you know, we're really into this.
You know?
And we gotta, we don't wanna stop this.
But we can't make a living from it here.
So let's go to Los Angeles.
So we packed up everything in a big U-Haul
truck.
The boards from the stage, the costumes, the
wiring.
And we moved out to Los Angeles.
And did the show there.
And so now to skip to the movie.
Actually when we first came to Los Angeles.
We didn't know what we wanted to be.
I mean, a performing group.
Television.
Writers.
I don't think we ever thought of ourselves
really so much as directors.
We turned to that sort of because we wanted
control of our material.
But not because we were like born to do that.
Which is pretty obvious if you look at any
of our movies.
[laughter]
But we you know, at some point we said "OK,
film really is our media.
It's where we can take time and I don't know,
it's just, you know we're not that prolific.
We really like to take time to get.
We wanna be able to take the time to get it
right and have something that would last and
not just, you know.
Disappear after a week."
Or whatever.
So we, David saw John Landis, who directed
"Animal House" and "The Blues brothers", those
films.
But this was just after his first movie "Schlock"
and he was on the Tonight Show because he
was a 21 year old kid who had directed a film.
And David thought, geez, 21, maybe he'll talk
to us.
I mean, because we didn't know anybody still.
And we had done this all but we didn't, we
had, we didn't know anybody in the movie business.
And so David called him and he was nice enough,
he invited him to the show.
He came to the show and we took him out to
lunch.
And I remember he gave us a, we said "How
do you write a movie script?"
And he gave us the script to "American Werewolf
in London" [laughter] which happened much
later, you know.
But we, so we used the form and that's when
we stared to write the first draft of "Airplane"
and then when we couldn't get that going,
we decided that maybe a way to get a movie
going was to do a really low budget film of
different bits.
And there had already, "Groove Tube" had done
that and been successful.
So again we followed in the steps of "Groove
Tube."
Does that answer your question?
More than you ever wanted.
Yeah, go ahead.
[laughter]
>>male #4: I was gonna ask you since you directed
with the trio and by yourself.
Kind of, the differences.
And what it's like to have three, directing
with two other people with you.
>>Jerry: When you direct by yourself you get
all of the credit and all of the blame.
[laughs]
But, and it actually is really good to share
both.
Ironically.
It's great.
In the days of success.
It was great to go "Alright!
Guys!" because you can't just go out in public
and say "Hey!
I made that movie!" you know.
So it's just sort of, we had a, Dave and Jim
and I grew up together.
We were, Dave and I are brothers.
It was, you know, we had a, it was a great
trio.
Not that we didn't argue and you know, beat
each other up a little bit.
But we really, we loved each other.
And we needed each other and it was great.
I think what happened is eventually, particularly
when we stopped doing satire.
I mean "Ruthless People" was a little harder
'cause it was a comedy but it wasn't a satire.
So there were more arguments 'cause that movie
could've gone in different directions.
Different filmmakers could've made different
films.
Whereas "Airplane" or "Naked Gun", there was
really only one film to be made of that.
Anyway, so it, we, and also I think that when
we started we really didn't have the courage.
I don't think we would have, I don't think
if either of us, any of us, had come out here
alone we would have ever had the nerve to
direct a film on our own.
So it just took a while for us.
Because like I said, we didn't come out like,
with, you know.
We, directing really takes sort of a lot of
kind of nerve.
Or it takes some bravado.
It takes some confidence.
It, which we didn't have.
You know, individually, I don't think.
And so but we did collectively.
And so, but yeah.
Directing alone, at some point, you kind of,
it is nice to make all the decisions.
It is nice to make the film you wanna make.
And it's, you know it's a mixed thing.
I mean, I do, I enjoy that.
And I've liked that experience but on the
other hand, I don't know, the three of us
was great.
You know?
So.
It's they're both, it's both good.
You have the mic, so go ahead.
>>male #5: One of the things I was struck
by watching you tonight was how well a lot,
so many of the jokes have held up.
And you were saying you didn't expect that
it would be around for decades.
>>Jerry: Yeah.
>>male #5: But did you consciously do this
mix of jokes?
To really try to balance it between these
very period, very specific that you have to
get the reference versus, it seems incredibly
balanced.
>>Jerry: Uh.
Yeah.
I don't think we did that purposefully.
I mean, 'cause we weren't t thinking.
We just wanted people now to laugh.
[laughing] We weren't thinking about years
from now, you know.
And, but I think that one of the reasons it
holds up is it's really a lot of it is just,
as I mentioned before, it's a satire on a
style of acting.
And so that kind of thing, holds up.
The stuff that doesn't is, are the lines that
are specific to a commercial.
Or a television show.
Or a movie.
You know.
And even some of the movies like the Saturday
Night Fever, you know.
People.
That movie has held up.
Is still with us on DVD.
So to the extent that we pick those movies,
we're alright.
And I think a lot of times certain things
skirt by that even if you don't know the reference
it's, it passes.
You know.
That joke is going along to the next.
So but no, we, it wasn't something, it was
something that happened.
But, and I agree with you, but it wasn't,
it was not purposeful.
[laughter]
>>male #6: Not to be over repetitive, but
I want to thank you very much for
>>Jerry: Over.
[chuckles]
>>male #6: "Airplane" and "Naked Gun" and
all, everything.
They were all depressingly formative for me.
[laughter]
So.
>>Jerry: Yeah.
I apologize, yes.
>>male #6: One thing that struck me when I
was watching was that you know, me and my
friends used to goof around because we watched
"Airplane" a lot.
And make kind of spoofy home videos.
And there were a lot of gags that seemed like
they were the kind of things we would have
added on the spot.
Like, the mayo in the back of the Mayo Clinic,
was the kind of thing that some of us would
think of.
Like, we're setting up the set "Well, why
don't we get as many jars of mayo as we can?"
Or like, Johnny.
And all his kind of antics.
And I wanna know, how much of the humor was
there on the paper before you even got other
people involved?
And how much of it was just kind of spur of
the moment and "Oh, we can do this with what
we have."
>>Jerry: About 99 percent was scripted.
It looks, it's nice that it looks like it's
and that's kind of the loose style of it in
a sense.
Although it really isn't loose.
But it, most of the script, even the stuff
that Johnny said.
But it's interesting.
That was a guy named Stephen Stucker who used
to be in our show in Kentucky Fried Theater
in Los Angeles.
And he has his own particular style of humor
and we really couldn't write for him.
And so [laughter] what we would do is, we
would call him up and we'd read him the setup
line.
And he'd just come up with the punch line.
[laughter]
You know.
And he was just really, is a very, he's just
like that.
I mean, that's Steve.
He's not this really serious guy who says
"Yes, I can play that character."
He's, this was kind of was him.
So we'd say, "OK" say, "Well what does the
plane look like?" and he goes "Oh, it's like
a big Tylenol."
And he'd say, you know.
And a couple lines were things from the show.
"What can you make outta this?"
"Oh, I can make a hat or a brooch or a pin."
You know.
[laughter]
And so, it's you know, but yeah, it was scripted.
In other words, when he said it, we liked
it because our feeling was, the things that
would work were generally things that were,
had been in the script and stood the test
of time.
Because a lot of times the problem with improve.
Ach, it seems so funny at the moment, but
then, is it really funny the next day or the
next day?
And it's, a lot of times the answer is no.
There was one thing I remember that was added.
Was, we had the written in the script was
the slapping of the woman.
Of this hysterical woman.
But I think that was it.
He just slaps her and leaves her, maybe, and
then Leslie slaps her.
But we added on the set, we added the thing
of all the other people waiting in line with
a gun and the whip and the whatever.
So that's, that was, there were a couple things.
But really in all our films, particularly
the satires, were very.
And we really were, wanted people to stick
to the script.
We didn't, I think as long as you said that
no more questions I'll just keep talking,
OK.
Because I didn't wanna.
You can, this is like, anyway.
We can take one more.
He had a question that he was just dying to
ask here.
OK, go ahead.
[audience chattering]
I mean, I'm fine, if you're, I, don't wanna.
I don't know.
You guys probably sleep here anyway right?
[laughter]
>>male #7: It's kind of a half repeat of the
directing question
>>Jerry: Oh.
>>male #7: about doing your first movie directing.
But first I wanna say, I appreciate the many
levels of humor in "Airplane."
And, moving from silly to absolutely completely
silly.
Probably
[laughter]
>>Jerry: A wide range.
>>male #7: Probably a year or two ago on TCM,
they had a day of those airport movies.
They had "Zero Hour."
And there was one with John Wayne and Robert
Stack.
I think it was called "House in the Sky" or
something.
>>Jerry: Uh.
"The High and the Mighty?"
Or
>>male #7: Maybe.
It was all, it was like so "Airplane" as I
was watching it I realized.
>>Jerry: Yeah, yeah.
"The Crowded Sky."
>>male #7: Oh my God, Robert Stack!
>>Jerry: There's a ton.
We watched all of them.
>>male #7: Yeah, yeah.
So I went back and I rewatched "Airplane"
after that and I just, I so appreciate the
levels of it.
'Cause when I first saw it I was like, eight.
And had no idea there was this genre.
The other thing I was just curious about
>>Jerry: You weren't into genres at eight?
[laughter]
>>male #7: Movie-lover for life.
But yeah, "The High and the Mighty."
It was amazing, it was hilarious.
I went back and rented because of that.
But.
>>female audience member: [inaudible]
>>male #7: Oh, well, if you
>>Jerry: If you look, if you ever have a chance
to go back and look, to watch "Zero Hour",
it's pretty shameless.
Because there actually is a line where the.
I mean, the story, we bought the rights because
we took the story.
We didn't know anything about plot.
You know.
[laughter]
And so it actually, it has the same plot.
It's a guy, in this case, in "Zero Hour" he's
chasing his wife who's leaving him because
he can't make a go of it because of what happened
during "The War".
[laughter] Of course, in that movie there
actually was a war, that was, that he was
referring to.
But he, and there was, and then there's food
poisoning and the whole deal.
But there actually is that line in that, in
"Zero Hour".
We took verbatim where he says "The life of
everybody on board this plane depends on just
two things.
Finding someone back there who not only can
fly this plane, but who didn't have fish for
dinner."
[laughter]
You know, stole that verbatim.
[laughter] Not a line changed.
And we, and it's just must be funny if I don't
know if Hall Bartlett who wrote that ever
saw "Airplane".
But it gets a big laugh in "Airplane" and
you know.
[laughter]
>>male #7: I was curious, too, about it being
your first time directing and the three of
you, all three of you, your first time.
How much, if any, that you rehearsed?
How did you approach the actors like Robert
Stack and Lloyd Bridges and said "Hey, we
loved you in this" you know, that kind a thing?
And how was it, if what you remember of your
impressions directing it when you were actually
shooting.
Were you guys crazy nervous or were you confident
by then?
Or was it a fun set?
Or was it really serious, or?
>>Jerry: I don't remember sleeping a lot the
night before the first day.
But it was, but we were, it was, I look at,
look back at it as one of the most fun experiences
in my career.
It was a, just exciting and a blast.
And not that any movie, you're always like,
"Oh my God, what are we gonna do.
This isn't working" [inaudible] but you know,
but, the actors in terms of how we got them.
We, some, Howard Koch was helpful because
he sort of, you know, was respected.
And told these guys that we were OK.
A lot of them like Peter Graves really didn't.
He actually thought the script was atrocious
[laughter] And he, you know, but how I got
all these guys to meet, it was actually Peter
Graves' wife loved it.
And his kids thought it was great.
And they were sort of encouraging them.
And he said "Why do you want me?
Don't you want one of the big?
Like Dom Delouise?
Or one of the big comó" Well, you know, at
the time, he was a bit.
I don't know if that's the right name, but
whoever was in the Jack Lemmon.
I don't know.
Walter Matthau.
Whatever.
But we said, we said "No, we think you'll
be funnier."
[laughs] And we explained that we just wanted
to play it straight.
We wanted him to be just like he was in Mission
Impossible or Fury or any of these shows that
he'd ever done.
And they were all kinda different.
Peter Graves is a lovely guy.
Wonderful, wonderful guy.
And he just, he didn't really completely get
it.
But he loved it later.
When he saw it.
[laughter]
And his wife was just hysterical in the first
screening for after the movie was finished
for everybody.
And, but he just, he kind of was just totally
cooperative.
You know.
So we would tell him a lot.
"OK say the line.
Then say this line.
Look up.
Say that line, then look down, then look back."
Like particularly with the little boy.
That's kinda tricky stuff.
[laughter]
So, we really explained to him when he could
look at him, 'cause if he looks at him and
says "Have you ever seen a grown man naked?"
it's not gonna work.
[laughter] You know so he has to say "Joey,
have you ever seen a grown man na--?"
So, you know we, but he was totally cooperative
and played it just like, you know, and it
was great.
Lloyd Bridges was a little different.
He was the one and Lloyd, I think, is fantastic
in the film.
But you can kinda see that he was the one
that wanted to be funny a little bit.
You know?
He was the one who is, who I think, I felt
was the, had the most trouble controlling.
But in the end, it kind of worked.
And it was fine and it gave us different levels.
And so I like, in a lot of situations, it
just, it we had some argument but it worked
out great.
And he was also a great guy.
He was a great guy, Lloyd.
So that was already great.
That was good.
Robert Stack was a good, Robert Stack is not
really a comedian, but he got it.
He got it and he looked and there was one
moment actually in rehearsals where Lloyd
Bridges was asking "Why would my character
say this line?"
You know, it's like, trying to think about
it really.
Think it through.
[laughter]
Like an actor's role.
You know, this is not, Stanislavsky will not
help you here.
[laughter]
So he, so but Stack just, you know and we're
kind a still young.
Rehearsal is--.
Young kids.
So for us, you have to understand these guys
were major stars and heroes for us.
Because we grew up with all of them.
But Stack just said, he said "Lloyd, who cares,
there's a spear going in the wall behind you
and a watermelon falling in front of me.
Just keep talking Lloyd.
Nobody's lookin' at us."
You know?
[laughter]
Which was great 'cause he really, Stack was
just, he kind of, he knew.
He said "We're the Stooges."
But he was willing to do that.
And thought it was appropriate and all.
And it, lovely, lovely guy.
Robert Stack.
And then, Leslie Neilsen.
Who then, I remember the casting agent was
couldn't understand why we wanted Leslie Neilsen.
He kept saying "Leslie Neilsen is the guy
you go to the night before, when you can't
get anyone else."
And we said "No, no, he's got that thing.
Really, he'll be perfect for the doctor."
And Leslie Neilsen was the one that was a
fish in water.
Leslie said later "I would have paid you guys
to do this."
Would he?
[laughter]
Yeah, no, but I think he meant it.
And Leslie, it's interesting, people always
ask "were you surprised that he was so good
at comedy?"
And my reaction is really, "No, I was more
surprised that he did drama all those years."
Because he really is an nutty guy.
It's not like he's a serious guy but he turns
on a thing and he can do comedy.
It was, he's a nutty guy who can get into
that serious mode and be the captain of the
titanic.
Or the, what's that movie, the, anyway.
[laughter]
The movie where he says "Oh my God."
When the tidal wave comes.
Anyway.
So, the, before we're done someone has to
think of the name of that.
"Poseidon Adventure."
Thank you.
So, but he was, Leslie was a joy.
And he was an anarchist like we were.
>>male audience member: What about Kareem
Abdul Jabar?
Do you remember?
>>Jerry: Well, Kareem was great too.
We actually wrote the role for Pete Rose but
it was during baseball season so we couldn't
get Pete Rose.
[laughter] So we decided to cast, we decided
Kareem would be good, we'd go after Kareem.
So we went Kareem and I think we offered him
$25,000.
And his agent called back and says "It's gotta
be, he wants 30.
Because he wants to buy an oriental rug and
it costs 30."
And that's the only reason he'll do it.
[laughter]
And I thought to myself, this is the greatest
line I've ever heard from an agent.
[laughter]
I want this guy to represent me.
And so, but we really, really wanted him.
And of course even $5,000 on a three million
dollar movie was really, is a lot.
So we said "Yes."
So excited to have Kareem.
And like two weeks later, there's an article
in a little blurb in TIME Magazine featuring,
that shows Kareem in front of a big oriental
rug that he'd just bought.
[laugher]
For $30,000.
At some auction.
So who knew?
But Kareem was great.
Kareem was, it's funny, I was, Kareem was
not, you know, the, a skilled actor.
But he was also lovely.
Really a good guy.
Kind, of, you know, took a bit to get to know,
you know.
He's not like gregarious a bit.
He's a little more shy around people.
And of course, your neck, I mean, he's so
tall.
But he's really, but I grew very fond of Kareem
and I actually just saw him a year ago.
And it was funny.
He's, he says he that he always every time
he goes on an airplane, people, like the pilots
invite him up to the cockpit or whatever.
[laughter]
Stuff like that, and I thought, that's movie
must be really powerful if they're inviting
a guy named Kareem up to the cockpit.
[laughter]
In this day and age.
But no, no, no.
He was great.
And you know, really lucky to have had him
in the movie.
It's hard to imagine it without him.
Yeah.
>>audience member: Can you tell us about Auto?
>>Jerry: Auto?
Yeah, auto.
Actually there were two Autos.
One of which is I think rotting in my basement.
But anyway, the.
I don't know how much you think it'd be worth
on eBay.
>>audience member: [inaudible]
>>Jerry: Actually mine is the female one.
Because what they did is, we didn't, once
again low budget.
There really was only one that did the main
one that was used.
The second one was only for, it was like a
more of a balloon.
Like a little bit more like this kind of thing.
Where when she, when it takes it out, when
it's released from its seat, and it's sort
of grabbing her and stuff like that.
That, but, the one that I have was the Auto,
but at the, it's repainted to the female face
for the end of the film.
But that was a clever deal that they, I mean,
they made the head swivel, and they figured
out how to make it bounce up and down and
all that stuff.
So that was, Auto was fun.
So I guess on that note.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Jerry: But thank you.
You guys have been, I actually ended up loving
you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[applause]